we're gonna play a little game with you
it is called Noah's good cry in honor of
the EP coming out this Friday all
questions about crying basically okay
all right
the movie that you can't watch without
crying PS I love you oh so good dude
they added it to Netflix the other day
and I was like come on like don't do
this to me all the fields if you played
it right now I'd cry like really like I
just sorted sobbing so if I'm feeling
sad and like I need to cry but I can't
get the tears out and I'll watch
something like that and then I'll get
the tears out and it makes me feel
better the person in your life who makes
you cry of laughter oh my gosh my friend
Andrew Wells he's an amazing producer
he's super awesome but he makes me cry a
laughter - and my dad the last time that
you broke down and just let it all out
sobbed yesterday yesterday like twice
this week I do that all the time yeah
well you're going through I'm going
through it right now there's like
there's just a lot of like you know
sometimes life gives you things once and
then like you have like a break and then
sometimes it's just like man it's like
wow like life slow down for a second
yeah but it's about doing going on tour
everything's good it's all good vibes la
is a hectic place and so it's gonna be
good to get out of LA this song that
makes you cry mmm glass in the park Alex
Turner hmm yeah it's the best way to
bounce back from a cry you know every
time I finish crying you know when
someone will make you laugh and cry for
long and that's a really good feeling
it's like the little laugh and then
you're like sniffily and you're like
laughing and you're kind of still front
I do that all right maybe that's just me
like if somebody makes me laugh I'll
like start crying again
like you're being so nice okay last one
is your favorite comfort food when
you're when you're feeling like you're
gonna cry
honey coolers what are those they're the
bomb I can eat like ten of them and
like it's like the glazed doughnuts if I
ate 10 of those like I feel like I'm
just gonna throw ya there's something
about these honey coolers that I can put
down
[Music]